[Musik]
sind sie politisch korrekt machen keine
rassistischen oder sexistische witze
nennen das hier einen schokokuss und
rufen im restaurant nicht allein zahlen
tatsache ist um die politische
korrektheit ist ein streit entbrannt
für die einen ist sie ausdruck von
gegenseitigem respekt für die anderen
ein unerträglicher moralismus der
denkverbote transportiert wie viel
politische korrektheit sein muss und ob
es die nägel mit der politiker
correctness übertreiben
darüber diskutieren wir jetzt an
philosophischen stammtisch ich begrüße
sehr herzlich unsere stammgäste casino
merkur ständig auf zürich heute wohnhaft
in berlin
konrad paul liessmann aus wien und
ausbeute bei uns norbert bolz ist
ebenfalls aus berlin stellt professor
für medienwissenschaften an der
technischen universität in berlin ganz
herzlich willkommen
ihnen allen dass die politiker
correctness in einigen kreisen fast
schon zum schimpfwort wurde hat viele
gründe für den deutschen sprachraum
allerdings wird häufig ein ereignis aus
kristallisationspunkt genannt nämlich
die silvesternacht des jahres 2015 in
köln
die medien nannten sie die nacht der
schande
und das was danach folgte den niedergang
des journalismus das hätte er verschwieg
anfänglich die vorfälle und damit den
migrationshintergrund der täter für
diese berührungsangst entschuldigte sich
der sender später es war die angst den
fremden häusern in die hände zu spielen
die sich dadurch erst recht bestätigt
sahen in ihren vorwürfen gegen die lügen
presse politischer korrektheit
eine formulierung die im amerika der
neunziger jahre geprägt wurde als
kampfbegriff der konservativen rechten
gegen die liberale linke wie sie
political correctness spaltet seither
die usa die einen wollen
minderheitenschutz um jeden preis auch
wenn eher bizarre blüten treibt
die anderen sehen darin ein redeverbot
dass die öffentliche meinung und die
politische debatte lehnt wir können es
uns einfach nicht mehr leisten
der amazon politisch korrekt zu sein
nicht mehr leisten dermaßen politisch
korrekt zu sein
ich finde wir sollten es uns gar nicht
leisten politisch korrekt zu sein
die übrigen dieser kleine film ist
großartig in seiner präzision beschreibt
im grunde den gesamten tatbestand oder
das gesamte problem so wie ich es wenn
ich das sagen dass überhaupt noch nicht
im fernsehen gesehen habe denn das ist
ja auch ein bericht des fernsehens über
sich selbst beziehungsweise ein medien
die ihre eigene problematik darstellen
also insofern ist politische correctness
mittlerweile an einen punkt angelangt wo
diejenigen die sie verteidigen selber
erste zweifel bekommen bei uns in berlin
gibt es eine zeitung die tatsächlich
eine serie gestartet hat mit der
fragestellung haben wir es mit der
politische correctness übertrieben
ich würde allerdings sagen wir hätten
gar nicht damit anfangen sollen
denn sehr sehr schnell ist der
ursprüngliche kluge impuls der ja auch
in ihrem film angesprochen worden ist
ins absurde umgekippt das war nämlich
der kluge impuls tatsächlich
minderheiten zu verteidigen zu schützen
und ihnen artikulationen zu geben und
sie auch zu schützen gegen verbale
diskriminierung aber daraus ist
mittlerweile eine kultur der
überempfindlichkeit geworden die im
grunde maßlos ist und die im grunde
jedem die möglichkeit gibt aufzutreten
mit dem anspruch ich bin beleidigt und
ich will wieder gut machen aber jetzt
sagen ursprünglich war die idee eine
gute zusammen gegangen hätten gar nicht
anfangen sollen
wir hätten sich mit der politik
correctness anfangen sollen als kultur
als kultur des politischen moralismus
und der sprache gene und der spaß
verbote sondern man hätte dabei bleiben
sollen tatsächlich aktiv eine art
öffentlichkeit für diskriminierte
minderheiten staat zu machen
das ist aber wie gesagt sehr sehr
schnell zum politischen instrument
geworden und politik correctness ist ja
ein campus phänomen und in der
universität neigt fast jede
intellektuelle entwicklung zu einer ja
dazu exzessiv zu werden und das ist eben
sehr sehr früh passiert und leider
gottes haben wir nur noch diese
exzessive form vor uns die man kaum mehr
parodieren kann weil sie im grunde schon
selbst dotiert aber wenn ich jetzt genau
diesen hinweis nicht der campuskultur
aufreißen darf ja natürlich ich meine
über die vernünftigkeit von 20 jährigen
studierenden da können wir uns lage
streiten das ist klar das passt nicht
unbedingt sozusagen die politisch am
besten lösungen für die allgemeine
gesellschaft hervorbringt was junge
leute erstmal beschäftigt und politiker
correctness als krampus phänomen finde
in klammern die das umfeld der
hochschulen sowie den studenten haben da
immer natürlich radikale ideen und
wollen die welt verbessern was
allerdings mir scheint die geschichte
der politischen korrektheit tatsächlich
auch prägt ist dass gewisse konservative
kreise sich dann mit männer einen
komischen fuhr auf diese campuskultur
gestürzt haben und gesagt haben
woher soll jemandem der mund verboten
werden und das zu einem großen
politischen gesamtpaket gemacht haben
also die nicht den ort gegeben haben
dinge sind und politische korrektheit
ist meiner meinung nach vor allem als
polemischer begriff gegen politische
korrektheit ja groß geworden und es wird
immer unterstellt also es gebe eine
diktatur der politischen korrektheit
aber ich möchte jetzt gerne mal hören
was sie gerne sagen möchten was nicht
mehr gesagt werden darf es dann ja
dauernd leute in der großen öffentlichen
medien sehr laut und meinungsstark dass
sie jetzt nicht mehr sagen dürfen aber
was dürfen sie denn eigentlich nicht
mehr sagen
diese art von leichter historisierung
noch ein punkt das kann jetzt auch am
schluss noch plant also trunks agenda
war ja gegen politische korrektheit und
er konnte sich damit in der grob
unhöflich verletzt
sind und auch grausam und wirklich
unangenehm war zum mutigen kämpfer
stilisieren weil er gesagt hat das ist
gegen die diktatur der politischen
korrektheit die ihre meiner meinung nach
wirklich ein phantom ist glaube
allerdings nicht
eigentlich möchte von ihnen wissen
nutzen von thomas die kommen gleich dran
aber vielleicht noch ganz gut aus zu
nehmen lassen was möchten sie den wagen
auch sie nicht fahren kann
ich bin ja hier beobachter und versuche
zu analysieren also eine art
kulturanalyse zu machen
ich habe keine probleme das zu sagen was
ich sagen möchte
aber ich beobachte natürlich dass es
keineswegs so ist wie sie unterstellen
dass man sagen könnte was man will und
womöglich sogar großen erfolg damit
haben kann zu sagen was man will
die amerikanischen verhältnisse also die
tram verhältnisse lassen sich übrigens
überhaupt nicht auf europa übertragen
aber der entscheidende punkt ist doch
folgender wenn sie darauf hinweisen dass
es leute gibt die politisch sehr
unkorrektes äußern und damit auch ein
publikumserfolg haben kann man das an
einem beispiel sehr gut festmachen dem
sarrazin das war im grunde vor der
silvesternacht schon der erste große
knackpunkt das ist uns ganz kurz einen
thilo sarrazin der das buch geschrieben
habe deutschland schafft sich ab und an
habe der tugendterror wenn die fahrt hat
er wurde niedergemacht mundtot gemacht
sagt hatte zahllose mundtot gemacht das
zu behaupten wäre unsinnig denn er hat
ja einen massenerfolg mit zu einem
glühwein bis zum heutigen tag die leute
rennen in die bude ein wenn er irgendwo
eine vorlesung macht oder so ist der
entscheidende punkt ist nur der das ist
kein zeichen für meinungsfreiheit
einfach deshalb weil sarrazin ein paar
jahre ist er ist eine nicht existente
ist jemand der in der öffentlichkeit
sogar mit polizeischutz auftreten muss
und das scheint mir nicht der ausdruck
einer liberalen kultur zu sein
liessmann
also phantom ist es keines wenn es nicht
am campus dort spürt dass er auf schritt
und tritt ja gleich nehmen anderes
beispiel gezielte beispiele also etwa
die verpflichtung die mittlerweile neu
sortierten herrscht das politisch
korrekt
bei schriftlichen arbeiten und
niedlichen äußerungen geändert wird
jetzt kann man gegen diese art und weise
so etwas die parität der geschlechter
herzustellen natürlich so oder so denken
aber wie soll man an österreichischen
hochschulen üblich ist das arbeiten
negativ beurteilt werden völlig egal von
der wissenschaftlichen qualität nur weil
jemand nicht korrekt energie verwendet
halte ich für unerträglich weit alle
zusammen sprach gesetzlichen
sprachregelungen ob das selbstvertrauen
ist oder das österreichische wörterbuch
ist erkennen dieses ihm nicht genauer
verstehen wenn jemand eine
arbeitsleistung nicht schreit polizist
arbeit schlechter bewertet vor
schlechter bis negativ bewertet ja das
kommt vor
und dort endlich da geht es um mehr als
nur um ein von drogen sozusagen studien
erfolge davon abhängig gemacht ob sich
jemand diesen politisch korrekten
sprachgebrauch jetzt im hinblick auf
geschlechter sensibilität anschließt
oder nicht anschließt ist jetzt nicht
sagen es ist nur ein phantom das andere
ist natürlich haben solche politisch
korrekten denkweisen und die damals
einen moralischen ansprüche auch
auswirkungen über den campus hinaus ja
wir haben sowohl im deutschen pass in
österreich natürlich aufgrund auch der
vergangenheit dieser dein länder ständig
debatten welche straßen namen umbenannt
werden müssen da hält die namen noch
denen hier genannt worden war mit
personen zu tun haben oder von personen
stammen
die universität wien hat der adresse
sehr sehr lange dr karl lueger ring
carlo jaeger bürgermeister wien um die
jahrhundertwende ein äußerst
erfolgreicher bürgermeister aber auch
antisemit ganz ganz klar und
mittlerweile aber die auffassung also
dass dieser dunkle fleck der zweifellos
in dieser biografie dieses politikers
zu sehen war ausreicht um in bergheim
aus dem öffentlichen straßen
geschichtsbild zu streichen und jetzt
ist der presse positiv wie nicht mehr
karl lueger rings ein universitäts ring
darüber kann man diskutieren ja ich sage
nicht dass das prinzip er jetzt falsch
ist das so zu handhaben
aber es zeigt dass es nicht nur ein
phänomen handelt zahlen ist eine frage
der öffentlichen politischen moral ist
eine frage da ein bestimmten form von
gesellschaftspolitik und ich denke man
braucht eine gewisse sensibilität um
solche fragen zu diskutieren und auch
was mich daran interessiert ist nicht so
sehr das aktuelle politische
unmittelbare diskurse politische praxis
soll sie umbenennen was sie unter den
bäumen straßen sind immer umbenannt
worden je nach politischer konjunktur
sondern mich interessiert viel mehr zum
beispiel geschichtsphilosophische
konzept dahinter
in einer stadt leben zu wollen wir uns
nicht aber auch nicht kein gebäude kein
name kein straße und zog ein denkmal an
zeiten erinnert die im politisch
moralisch nicht einwandfrei gewesen sich
auch wahnsinnig interessant und
natürlich sind diese dahinter steckt
nämlich genau jenes phantasma von
reinheit der dass wir auf der anderen
seite den großen verkündern geologische
rassistischen nationalistischen
freiheiten zu recht vorwerfen zu recht
vorwerfen und der verfahren selbst diese
reinheitsgebot und das sind etwa
philosophisch interessant an einem
begriff den kontext und politischer
korrektheit immer auf politische hygiene
aber bis ende juli gestartet ich habe
schon so viele sind ja auch nur
zustimmen ich finde diese politischen
debatten die wir führen auch diese
moralischen debatten wie sollen wir
sprechen wie soll unsere städte benannt
die straßen am benannten dass da ganz
viele implikationen sind klar und das
sind aktuelle fragen wogegen ich mich
wäre es gegen diese diese
verschlagwortung politiker correctness
als gegner
weil politiker zu wagnis ist nur ein
politischer kampfbegriff mit dem einfach
etwas abgebügelt werden soll das dann
alles in eine diffuse ecke gestellt wird
wir können uns darüber streiten wie
inwiefern geschlechtergerechte sprache
sinnvoll ist
was für straßenbenennungen sinnvoll sind
aber wenn wir alles sozusagen mit diesem
reaktionären kampfbegriff nämlich
politiker zur existiert da innerhalb der
linken nur als selbst verballhornung des
kam in den 70er jahren auf was da hat
man sie automatisch waren aus politisch
korrekt bezeichnet und es gibt sogar
selbstbezeichnung viel weniger als kampf
kampfbegriff auftaucht und ich finde wir
machen aus diesem doch der bedenken
werden themen wie gehen wir mit sprache
um wie gehen wir mit
geschichtsbewusstsein um einfach eine
sozusagen eine platte kampfzone mit
denen die über das durfte man noch sagen
um denen die man darf nicht mehr sagen
man macht ein problem dass tatsächlich
besteht in einer
geschichtsphilosophischen dimension und
in eine sensibilität dimension zu einem
plumpen politischen kampf und noch ein
wort zu dem man darf weiterhin ja fast
alles sagen und das große schreien dass
man es nicht mehr sagen dass es ist
nicht so dass man nicht kritisiert wird
für das was man sagt und es wird ja
immer den campus kulturen vorgeworfen
das sex ist ein neues baby schneeflocken
sind immer alle bereit sind zu sensibel
sie können keine meinung ertragen die
nicht die ihre ist aber ich finde
natürlich umgekehrt die leute die
dauernd sozusagen klagen dass die
politische korrektheit ihnen nicht mehr
erlaubt irgendwas zu sagen
das finde ich es die wahre snow flickr
sowie die die schließen sich an der art
und weise dieser beleidigungs gibt
kultur der die sie anderen vorwürfen
genau an diesen
ich darf ja nichts mehr was hat sie
leider diese begriffe nicht mehr
brauchen wenig daraus gibt nur leicht
mit wurde um das problem zu klären
im übrigen war das der allererste reflex
der campus linken in amerika die these
aufzustellen politisch korrekt es
existiert überhaupt nicht das ist nur
ein kampfbegriff der rechten das so das
war der start relativ fragen ich würde
sagen das ist unsinn aber wir können
diese diskussion dadurch glaube ich in
besseres fahrwasser bringen indem wir
uns überlegen was steckt eigentlich in
der politik korrektes oder was sind die
elemente aus dem sich zusammensetzt es
sind viele ich nenne meine gemeinschaft
und wichtigsten sind zwei dass auf der
einen seite politischer moralismus und
auf der anderen seite sprach sich jene
und ich glaube ein blitz sprache gehen
die nachher an was ich den politischen
radikalismus bedeutet über politische
probleme nicht politisch zu diskutieren
sondern sie im gut böse kategorien
aufzuteilen das heißt also dass sie wenn
sie und nehmen wir mal das klassische
beispiel der realpolitik der 90 bis 19
das frühen zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
keine der realpolitischen entscheidungen
lässt sich mit der moralischen
kategorien gut oder böse in irgend einer
sinnvollen weise diskutieren
aber genau das tun wir heute den
benutzten im grunde jedes thema und jede
information um sie mit bestimmten
meinungen zu regieren
und wenn sie diese meinung nicht
vertreten manipulieren sie sich in das
politische abseits
das eben heute als politisch unkorrekt
gilt und dass eben nicht nur kritik
heraus fordert das ist das
selbstverständlich dass meinung kritik
heraus wurde sondern sie werden
sanktioniert in einer moralischen weise
und gelten als unmensch ich nenne hier
nur immer noch einen hinweis auf die
ganze sache was das extrem des
politischen moralismus ist das ist
hoffentlich in der schweiz nicht ganz so
wie in deutschland
in deutschland wenn zu einer position
vertreten die beispielsweise in
schlüsselfragen unserer zeit wie etwa
flüchtlingspolitik aber auch europa die
politische zukunft europas und ähnliches
nicht die meinung der großen koalition
zwischen politischer klasse und
mainstream journalismus vertreten wenn
sie da außerhalb sind gelten sie
zunächst einmal als rechts was kein
problem ist warum nicht recht wenn sie
aber recht sind sind sie gleichzeitig
rechtspopulistisch wenn sie
rechtspopulistisch sind gehören sie
wahrscheinlich zur afg oder zur feder
und dann sind sie eigentlich schon ein
nazi das heißt es gibt es gibt ein
slippery slope einen verhängnisvollen
abhang den man wahnsinnig schlecht
schnell herunterrutscht wenn man sich in
irgendeiner weise vom mainstream der
meinungen abkoppelt also von der
politischen moral ist es nicht eine
vereinfachung stimme wirklich bei uns
bedeutet in jedem fall und es könnte an
jedem dieser themen ganz glauben kann
das schon sehr gut überprüfen
für das jetzt auf die schnelle nicht das
gesamte beispiel
dafür dass es natürlich leute gibt die
recht sind und die konservativ sind und
die mit einer differenzierten meinung in
der öffentlichkeit stehen dann sollte
man kurz drüber nachdenken da glaube ich
gibt es einige man wird schnell zum
rechtspopulisten wenn man
rechtspopulistisch unterwegs ist und
polemisiert wenn man hingegen mit einer
differenzierten rechten meinung in der
öffentlichkeit steht und da fangen wir
eigentlich auch viele journalisten da
würde ich meine wenn wir sagen wir haben
eigentlich brauchen wir ein ideal eines
differenzierten öffentlichen diskurses
in dem unterschiedliche meinungen mit
einer vernünftigen basis ausgetragen
doch es gibt nirgendwo
das ist 100 iger sieht ja so ganz weiß
es nicht und buden dran verarbeiten ich
möchte an dieser stelle eine einen
kommentar einbringen einer zuschauerin
regina probst hat uns geschrieben und
das ist nämlich genau das passiert
gerade gesagt haben frauen york hat uns
geschrieben politiker correctness ist
unentbehrlich in ihrem kern wenn ihr
sowas sie einen kultivierten umgang
untereinander pflegen wollen also ein
plädoyer für kritiker correctness damit
ihr gepflegt miteinander sprechen können
nein das überhaupt nicht einzig
überhaupt nicht ein nur als kleiner
nachtrag als kleiner nachtrag zu dem was
sie gesagt haben
der fall jörg butt zum beispiel dass ein
hervorragender osteuropa historiker der
wirklich bahnbrechende arbeiten anstatt
die songs geschrieben hat der sich in
fragen etwa der märkischen
flüchtlingspolitik kritisch dazu
geäußert hat und der ist jetzt der
rechte der wirt vom boden wieder
ausgeladene dem diskutiert man nicht der
steht unter dauerbeobachtung einer rede
an dessen beruf wie der historiker aber
da möchte ich jetzt auch mal nachfragen
was ich denn einig dass probleme haben
die beide gesagt man wird dann in die
rechte ecke gestellt
das problem ist dass er eine rechte ecke
steht mit dem diskutiert man nicht mehr
immer noch viel diskutiert in
deutschland dass ich die zweite woche im
interview mit barbara frey und der wird
auch nach wie vor als experte geschäft
dezember in london einer der anlass für
energie zwar halten die faz dazu bewogen
hatten artikel oder eine sehr fragile zu
schreiben wo kritisch nachgefragt wurde
ob es wirklich diese freiheit der
wissenschaft die das fundament zum
wissenschaft sein muss an deutschen
universitäten noch gibt also es kann
fans die sich alle ihren es kann sein
dass die alle im falschen blick auf die
realität haben
es kann sein dass das so sagen die
wahrheit hier gepachtet sitzt aber ich
bin skeptisch aber prinzipiell noch
einmal passieren kann ist dass er diese
einfälle da kann man immer sagen ich
verunglückt ist spitze eines eisberges
ist ein einfacher oder regel kann man
lange diskutiert ich frage mich prinz
gewählt und das hat mich viel mehr ob
wirklich für einen zivilisierten umgang
miteinander so politische korrektheit
notwendig ist wenn ich unter politischer
korrektheit der ganze dadurch nimmt es
sehr von sprach vorschriften von spar
normierungen und davor verhaltensweise
verstehe glaube ich kommen dafür die
darauf verzichten weil ich würde ganz
was anderes stark machen wollen wir zum
beispiel bestimmte formen von
höflichkeit zu ihrem stark machen wollen
ich werde stark machen wollen bestimmte
formen von sensibilität
ich verstehe herum von jüngsten sitzung
durchaus auch wenn ich sozusagen aus
selbstbewusster und autonom bestimmte
autonomie anspruch wird darüber gedanken
machen klar werde wie ich sprach ich mit
meinem gegenüber umgehe dann brauche ich
nicht regeln an die ich mich halten muss
und durch sofort begann gar nur ein
falsches oder vermeintlich falsches wort
eine vermeintlich kreise formulierungen
verwenden oder als versorgen vielleicht
auch gar nicht bewusst wenn nico
aggression losgelassen habe werde ich
eine frau für hübsch erklärt habe und
die anderen frauen daneben steht indes
kommentar diesmal ist die koalition
ich möchte ihnen gleich nach ihrem wort
gehen schauen wir kurz was micro
aggression sicher tatsächlich so eine
frage ist nicht nur aber die frage ist
nicht nur was man sagt sondern wie man
es sagt und in diesem kontext ist das
stichwort nico aggression ganz wichtig
geworden
schauen wir da zu kurz einen 1 1 1
spielen
die unis in den usa die moralischen
gewissen des landes darum nicht
erstaunlich dass dort der begriff micro
aggression entsteht das ziel der
generation micro aggressionen verhindern
also eine aggression die mikro subtil
passiert gegen minderheiten gerichtet
ist aufgrund etwa von geschlecht
aussehen oder nationalität beispiele
woher kommst du eigentlich wirklich
impliziert du lügst zwar hier ist aber
doch fremd du liest heute gut aus
verstanden wird sonst eigentlich nicht
so im mikrobereich kann vieles bedeuten
aufsicht gelassen wird die diskussion in
den usa geführt beispiel universität
yale
ich habe euch gehört es tut mir leid
eine entschuldigung vor aufgebrachten
studenten
der professor hatte gefordert
provokative halloween kostüme an der uni
zu erlauben zu viel der aggression
auch wenn sie den rassismus den bio
spüren nie erfahren werden können sie
nicht einfach so tun als gäbe es andere
dinge nur noch schweigen eines landes
wie der usa wäre das unwürdig wo doch
freie meinungsäußerung und redefreiheit
zu den höchsten gütern gehören missionen
kann ich nicht so viel anfangen ich
finde ja auch dieses ehepaar ich bin
wahnsinnig interessant weil da wirklich
einfach also wie duell ist ein mob und
sich sind sie kommen sie ihm sehr nahe
also die bedrohung seien eher umgekehrt
zu sein
ich finde aber das scheint mir aber auch
wiederum sehr typisch meint man greift
sich eben diese einzelnen beispiele auf
und lebt die zusagen heraus und lädt die
auch zu einem allgemein problem und ich
möchte doch noch mal gerne kurz darüber
nachdenken worüber reden wir eigentlich
ich finde gewisse formen dessen was als
politische korrektheit verstehen wird
sind fragen der höflichkeit wie begegne
ich einmal anderen sensibel wie spreche
ich ihn an was sind sozusagen die
sensiblen stellen die möchte ich also
ich finde schon auch vor etwa seine
höflichkeit des herzens jemanden so zu
bezeichnen der sich selber bezeichnen
möchte und so weiter auf den drei jetzt
so etwas wie ein
ein mann oder frau angesprochen werden
möchte darauf eingehen ja und zum
beispiel finde ich dass man zumindest
darüber nachdenken wollte was gewisse
sprach vorschläge zur sprach erneuerung
bedeuten in bezug auf die
machtverhältnisse innerhalb einer
sprachgemeinschaft usw
das ist eine und ich glaube dass wir
davon aber schon noch mal unterscheiden
werden müssen und es wird aber immer in
einen topf geworfen
diese wild gewordenen linken und zwei
ministerien und überhaupt ist was
sozusagen die die politische frage
betrifft wenn wir zum beispiel über
politische flüchtlingspolitik reden wenn
wir über realpolitische fragen sind bei
sie haben dass nämlich auch gerade
gesagt also die moralisierung von
politik das eine ist gesellschaftliche
debatten natürlich sind die moralisch
was sollen die denn sonst seien es ist
die frage wie wollen wir zu wahren leben
die frage von realpolitik da gibt es
schon noch mal andere themen und ich
würde das aber irgendwo auch voneinander
unterscheiden also das wird ja leider
nicht getan verbrechen offizielle
politik gender mainstreaming ist eine
offizielle politik die nicht nur den
universitäten betrifft erklärungs
offiziell bettringer wird und die von
der eu ausdrücklich betrieben wird also
da kann man nicht davon reden dass die
gesellschaft sich über die höflichkeit
des herzens und ihre folgen oder ihren
möglichkeiten verständigen würde
wir haben es mit einer mit einem neuen
jacobi nist muss zu tun wir haben das
mit einem tugendterror zu tun
der von leuten aus gelebter die an macht
stellen sitzen die sitzen in regierungen
besitzen an der spitze von universitäten
und sie sitzen vor allen dingen auch in
den redaktionen
sonst würden ja diese fragen gar nicht
aufkommen zu zwischen sich ja
mittlerweile nicht auch medien selber
die frage stellen haben wir es mit der
politische correctness übertrieben das
sind ja leute die längst dazu
übergegangen sind im gegensatz zu dem
was sie meinten politische correctness
als positiven begriff als
selbstbeschreibung der eigenen
positionen zu betrachten aber der kern
ist doch folgender und das macht die
mikro aggression er so deutlich dass ich
einfach nur noch absurd finde diese
ganze betrachtung das hat ihr beitrag
auch wie das finde ich super deutlich
gemacht
wenn wir auf empfindlichkeiten in
irgendeiner weise eingehen als maßstab
für gesellschaftliche zusammenleben
kommen wir aus den regulieren und
letztlich ausschließen der kommunismus
nie wieder heraus das entscheidende für
das zusammenleben in einer gesellschaft
darf nicht die höflichkeit des herzens
sein
das kann man sich wünschen und das
sollte man kultivieren sondern das
entscheidende für das gesellschaftliche
zusammenleben muss zwar dass sein
auf der einen seite toleranz im sinne
auch das ertragen von anderssein und das
ertragen zu anderer meinungen
das bedeutet aber auch ertragen der
kritik die man selber erfährt oder der
art und weise wie man angegangen wird
sie haben ja auch gesagt man sollte doch
nicht so empfindlich sein und auf kritik
reagieren aber genau das ist es doch das
ist eine überempfindlichkeit und auf der
anderen seite ist es eben denke ich
fundamental dass wir uns darauf besinnen
dass unser gesellschaftliches leben
durch das rechtssystem geregelt wird
und wenn jemand in einer weise beleidigt
wird das dass das recht empfindlich ist
recht empfindlich und nicht subjektiv
empfindlich dann gibt es entsprechende
regelungen und gesetze um sanktionen
auszusprechen aber es gibt keinerlei
notwendigkeit über diesen rechtsrahmen
in irgendeiner weise hinauszugehen und
wenn sie so wollen von oberlehrer
perspektive aus die gesellschaft dazu zu
zwingen bestimmte dinge nicht mehr zu
sagen bestimmte verhaltensweisen eine
zwei- oder wie man ablehnt und schlecht
findet was ich da ganz kurz ein haken in
der zeit diese woche einen großen
artikel sehr lesenswert wo kommst du
eigentlich her da wir genau diese frage
diskutiert darf man diese frage noch
stellen und ich muss zugeben nicht
wieder selber auch schon reingetragen
ich habe auch schon menschen gefragt mit
fremdländischen namen woher kommst du
eigentlich habe das neugierig freundlich
gemeint und wurde dann entsprechend
darauf hingewiesen dass die frage nicht
mehr stellen in diesem artikel wird
dargelegt dass das heute nicht mehr
einfach ausdruck von neugier oder nicht
mehr so verstanden wird auch ausdruck
von neugier sondern eben auch mikro
aggression von gewissen leuten jetzt die
eigentliche frage um die fand ich
interessant stellt sich doch schon wären
da nicht die fragenden wir hier sind
keine personen die wahrscheinlich je
diskriminiert worden sind vielleicht
wie auch frauen ich weiß es nicht aber
wir sind gut gebildet sind weiß wir
sitzen beruflich fest im sattel
um wen ist es eigentlich zu sagen wann
es ausreicht mit politiker korrekt ist
ist es nicht an denjenigen das zu sagen
dieselben opfer sind von diskriminierung
ich glaube diese frage müssen wir schon
stellen womöglich wäre das endschießen
menschen werden über westlichen welt zur
iss ist geschützt es gibt doch längst
juristische regelungen gegenüber
diskriminierungs sonst gäbe es das
moderne gesellschaftliche zusammenleben
seit jahrhunderten nicht also es gibt
gar keinen bedarf an einer neuregelung
das neue ist nicht dass menschen stärker
diskriminiert würden als früher
diskriminierung ist so alt wie die
menschheit und es wird zu langes
zivilisation gibt auch diskriminierung
geben weil es ja eigentlich nur heißt
grenzen ziehen unterschiede machen und
ähnliches mehr
das wird immer so sein aber neu ist dass
man die empfindlichkeit also das
subjektive empfinden wie ist meine
situation innerhalb der gesellschaft
dass man das versucht zum maßstab zu
nehmen und dann gibt es im grunde nur
noch einen der wirklich authentisch
urteilen kann das ist dass einzelne
subjekt selber der einzelne der sagt ich
bin beleidigt worden ich bin
diskriminiert worden
man spielt mir übel mit und dafür will
ich in irgendeiner weise aber eigentlich
ich glaube schon dass sprache mächtig
ist es gibt zum beispiel untersuchungen
die zeigen dass jugendliche mit einem
fremden enormen in der schweiz ist sehr
viel schwieriger haben eine lehrstelle
zu finden
die personen die einen schweizer bünzli
namen haben wenn ich morgen sagen darf
dass sprache macht natürlich immer
einfach mit uns wird auch zu dieser
frage woher kommst du zuerst eine
anekdote erzählen und dann zu den
prinzipien puppen gerne kurzwahl sagen
aber das eine ist also ich verstehe dass
schon mehr dass man solche fragen auch
in gewisser weise als anstößig oder als
als misstrauenserklärung auffassen kann
aber das muss ja nicht so sein ich denke
da kommt aus dem kommunikations kontext
ran ich habe zum beispiel einen
assistenten der hat leichter asiatische
gesichtszüge und einen ganz sicher nicht
europäischen namen spricht aber ganz
normal ist offensichtlich hier
aufgewachsen und habe nie gefragt wie
nie gefragt wo er kaum vorname bedeutet
gleich mehr sondern
ist aufgefallen leistung sich beworben
hat die stelle bekommen und später wenn
wie heute dann irgendwie auch ein café
sitzt und nicht nur in der forschung
diskutiert habe ich ihn gefragt
jetzt interessiert eigentlich schon was
bedeutet eigentlich dein name und ihr
habt gesehen wie ein strahlen über sein
gesicht gehen denn hat eine unglaublich
interessante lebensgeschichte hinter
sich und war heilfroh seinem scherz
diese geschichte erzählen zu können und
ich war heilfroh über ihn etwas erfahren
zu haben
was jetzt überhaupt keine auswirkung hat
wird die eine beurteilung seiner
leistung als eine position in zoppot
ohne ihn vorher bekommen und erfahren zu
haben ist einfach die
zwischenmenschliche kommunikation und
beziehungen in beiderlei hinsicht
bereichert hat und jetzt frage ich mich
was war hier andere genau auf was war
ihr diskriminierend aber ich hab ihm
wirklich diese böse frage gestellt bei
ihnen erhalte aber böse werte gewählten
vorhalte vor hat peter fox auf der
betonpiste stelle nicht also was er
wirklich furchtbar gewesen
das ist lächerlich soll es ist wohl
drauf es kommt auf den kommunikations
konnte der beamte
was mich an dieser politischen direkt
eine politik des verschifften stört es
ist dass man glaubt es gibt eine sprache
formulierung diese alle kontext entweder
richtig oder falsch gut oder böse ist
und das stimmt eben nicht das entwertet
wenn ich die unmittelbarkeit die
lebendigkeit die vielseitigkeit von
ledersitzen erste der beliebteste mensch
in der deutschen öffentlichkeit ranga
yogeshwar klingt nicht wahnsinnig
deutsch oder daran hat sich noch nie
irgendwie mal gestört ganz im gegenteil
wenn sie heute mal filme angucken oder
wenn sie sich einfach mal den namen
angucken die do's abspann von
irgendeiner dokumentarsendungen oder
sowas laufen ist das verhältnis von
deutsch klingenden namen und irgendwie
exotisch klingenden namen mindestens 50
zu 50
also dass ich daran jemand stören würde
ist jedenfalls für mich in der deutschen
öffentlichkeit nirgendwo es glaube diese
betroffenen werden sagen sie bringen
jetzt lauter beispiel ihren von von
arrivierten erfolgreichen menschen die
es geschafft haben und noch einmal zu
sagen wann politische korrektheit zu
viel ist die definition dass wir
sozusagen
das maß anzugeben wäre an denjenigen die
nach wie vor ist nicht existent das ist
ein phantom problem also ich glaube
tatsächlich dass ich wenn ich diese
diskussion habe ich ja auch schon öfter
geführt weiß nicht wer tatsächlich
gefragt woher ich komme beim einnahme
dann muss ich erklärt ich bin schweizer
reeder mein vater war engländer und das
sagen hat sie können gut deutsch ist das
fest der schweiz hofft wenn irgendwo
antrag gemacht und das interessante ist
ich fühle ich empfinde das nicht als
aktiv oder als quasi als antritt weil
ich nicht den eindruck habe es kommt mit
einem verdacht einher dass irgendetwas
daran falsch sein und die diskussion
habe ich aber schon oft mit
türkischstämmigen aber selbst auch
spanisch für training in tallinn
ständigen freundin gehabt die die
designer in deutschland wird mir dann
immer unterstellt weil ich ein bisschen
mediterraner aussieht dass irgendetwas
animiert weniger gut sei und das kommt
so ganz so rüber und also sie haben
tatsächlich zum teil 1 zu sehen also
selbst wo ich bei italienern und
spaniern denke ich mir gut aber hier
kommt es nicht auch aus westeuropa sie
ihr habt wirklich auch keine schwere
migrationsgeschichte hinter euch und da
gibt es also die sensibilität gefragt
ist im einzelnen anzulegen und klar für
mich ist es aber auch mit eine falsche
darstellung dessen worum es geht dass
wir diese frage nach dieser sensibilität
aufbringen muss möglicherweise bewusst
machen das ist vielleicht blöd sein kann
wenn ich jemand mit einer anderen
hautfarbe sofort woher kommst du frage
dass wir diese bewegen eben eine
karikatur zu sagen es gibt gesetze die
sagen wir dürfen nicht mehr fahren
konnten
ja ich habe gehört man muss dazu sagen
bei uns war das früher ein mohrenkopf
aber ich habe mich von meinen kindern
belehren lassen dass das politisch
unkorrektes ich versuche dies zu
vermeiden aber ich würde sie tatsächlich
nicht mehr mit diesen alten hessen
zwischen bezeichnung bezeichnen weil die
tatsächlich einfach historisch gesehen
ist daran eigentlich rassistisch das
habe ich nicht verstanden er die morgens
straße in berlin auch das ist bestimmt
einige denken darüber nach sie auch
umzusetzen
durch probieren dass die mauren ja
eigentlich eine überlegene kultur waren
sie wirklich den sonnabend feiert das
freut mich
das wäre natürlich noch die schönste
aufklärung der masse besser aufklären
ich bin sehr für aufklärung ich glaube
die worte die aber gleichzeitig in den
letzten zwei jahrhunderten einen sehr
starke konnotation mit auch
rassistischen politik und rassistischen
konnte ich versuche sie zu vermeiden
weil ich die möglichkeit hatte gegenüber
läuft können sie persönlich doch tun und
das ist wunderbar aber warum angepasst
werden
das ist unser thema das ähnliche war bis
eben nicht den kopf verloren kopf den
ich immer noch alles offen gesagt früher
noch nicht inkriminiert war habe ich
erst wurde kopf genannt wie alle anderen
menschen übrigens auch habe aber mich
belehren lassen dass das politisch
unkorrekt ist und mit sicherheit so dass
eine einsicht natürlich morgen kopf in
österreich übrigens gibt es eine
ähnliche weise denen wir schwere bomben
und das finde ich noch viel schöner
wirken bringt wieder zu sagen natürlich
soll man kann frei gewählt das wohl dazu
sagen wie er will aber bezeichnung einen
sprachlichen konversions kontext einmal
den sinn etwas eindeutig definierter zu
machen dass er irgendwann einmal muss
ich darüber entscheiden das geschäft
geht was steht dort was kaufe ich kann
natürlich auch sagen menschen können zu
salat auf gemüse sagen zu gemüse auch
durchsagen zu dieser auch speck sagen
nur wissen sie nicht was sie dann haben
das heißt dass er irgendwann einmal muss
festgelegt werden wie dieses ding
tatsächlich heißt damit identifizieren
kann
und da ist schon die frage bleibt mir
jetzt bei mohrenkopf oder findet man das
als rassistisch oder aus den
kulturkritischen gründen nicht mehr zeit
aber ich finde auch solche
traditionellen bezeichnungen gegenüber
die ihre geschichte haben die vielleicht
tatsächlich auch mit dem kommunismus zu
tun haben
kann man so noch auf bestimmte form von
aufgeklärt auch ironischer distanz
gegenüber haben was mich auch ein
bisschen stört da nicht sehr gute
ernsthaftigkeit mit der die dinge dann
verhandelt werden ja das mag saint amour
übrigens hat den deutschen
sprachgebrauch nie die rassistische
konnotation gehabt wird oder [ __ ] es
gab auch mal negativ oder nebel oder
süßspeisen
das wissen wir alle aber warum kann man
nicht sagen das ist eine tradition
speisen sowie was sich in österreich im
schnitt zu vergleichen mehr
wir kennen die problematik damit
zusammenhängen aber wir haben genug
ironische distanz damit umgeht so können
wir müssen nicht ganz ohne frage ist
eben diejenigen die betroffen sind die
ironische distanz haben können aber
machen wir natürlich auch bringen wir
haben genug beispiele wo an sich
diskriminierende begriffe von den
betroffenen aufgenommen wurde und wurde
und durch dienstgebrauch positiv
kommentiert wollen sehen oder klassische
schule zum beispiel aber im verlauf des
verfahrens aktion und kommunikation eine
ganze menge
die ironische distanz würde aber doch
glaube ich meiner meinung voraussetzung
dass menschen mit schwarzer hautfarbe
heutzutage gar keine rassistische
diskriminierung erfahren
sonst wird das schwierig wir können
diese distanz vielleicht aufbringen aber
wir kennen das problem wirklich nicht
von innen gut jetzt machen wir einen
schritt nämlich ihn zu den medien das
ist jetzt auch schon mehrere mal ist ein
bisschen durchgesickert was der
tugendterror eben die auch zu tun hat
mit einer veränderung der
medienlandschaft und in diesem kontext
waren sie auch erfolgs dass die freiheit
des denkens natürlich auch impliziert
dass man dieses denken auch formulieren
darf und öffentlich äußern und damit
sind hier bei einer bemerkung oder einer
zu schlicht wiederum eines zuschauers
nämlich von arthur punkte er hat uns das
folgende geschrieben politiker korrekt
ist einschüchterung und sprachpolitik
die kritische andersdenkende dämonisiert
als rechtspopulistisch stigmatisiert und
sie dankt medialen pranger zum schweigen
bringt medial abpraller das ist auch ein
begriff den referenten holz das ist eine
ideale pronger haben wir wirklich einen
medialen
mit sicherheit ist es bei uns wie gesagt
ich muss immer als gast hier aus
deutschland aufpassen nicht zu
generalisieren und ich weiß nicht wie
die schweizer oder österreichischen
verhältnisse sind bei uns geht es in
jedem fall
wir haben es allerdings auch mit einer
besonderen art von journalistik zu tun
in deutschland immer mehr journalisten
und zwar gerade in den sogenannten light
mädchen begnügen sich nicht mehr mit
informationsverarbeitung und
informationsdarstellung sondern glauben
den auftrag zu haben als pre zepter
germania als oberlehrer deutschland
aufzutreten
das heißt also das war das was ich schon
versuchte anzuschneiden bestimmte themen
mit bestimmten meinungen zu verschmelzen
ich glaube das ist der sündenfall des
journalismus schlechthin also nicht mehr
zu trennen zwischen information und
meinung und gerade wenn sie ins
fernsehen gehen ein medium das doch
immer noch sehr wichtig ist und gerade
wenn sie ins öffentlich rechtliche
fernsehen bei uns schauen können sie das
in massivster weise beobachten wir
hatten ja schon in ihrer einspielung das
beispiel des heute-journals oder der
heute nachrichten ich glaube gerade das
heute schon alles eins der massivsten
organe für diese verschmelzung von
meinung und thema und das bedeutet eben
wenn du zu einem bestimmten thema eine
andere meinung hast dann stehst du auf
der falschen seite dann gehörst du zu
den bösen und diese diese tendenz denke
ich sie ist sehr sehr stark und führt
letztlich über die das was die
medienwissenschaftler orientierung der
journalisten nennen
mittlerweile in deutschland zu einer art
großer koalition zwischen den politisch
mächtigen und den wichtigsten
journalisten die tatsächlich statt wie
wir das früher gewohnt haben kritisch
über die politik zu berichten
diese politik muss selber mit aller
macht unterstützen also gerade nicht
mehr die distanz der berichterstattung
waren aber eigentlich ist doch schon
kommentar und berichterstattung getrennt
sie sagen jetzt eingerissen aber aber
gerade im heute schon aus sieht man doch
das eigentlich sehr schön dass wir ja
getrennt und wenn ich eine zeitung
aufschlage dann schätze ich das sehr
dass ich ein bericht lesen kann um mir
dann die kommentare getrennte frau
müssten doch wissen dass man seit
jahrzehnten
studiert hat und analysiert hat dass es
ganz andere kommunikationsformen gerade
ansehen und sie müssen sich nur mal das
gesicht von herrn kleber anschauen oder
von marietta slomka wenn sie
irgendwelche abweichenden positionen ins
bild bringen
dieses gesicht spricht wirklich bände
und es bleibt eigentlich auch nicht nur
bei den gebärden und bei den bei den
physiognomien dieser leute sondern auch
in dem was sie sagen ist es keineswegs
so dass könnte man an einzelbeispielen
glaube ich sehr schön zeigen dass da
getrennt würde zwischen information und
ich verstehe auf eine art und weise die
sorge ich halte das problem allerdings
der medien heute tatsächlich ein anderer
für sie ich glaube ihr was das problem
ist ist boulevardisierung und
sozialisierung die tatsächlich meiner
meinung nach nicht mit einer vermischung
von information und meinung zu tun hat
sondern mit einer fotoshow visierung
also letztlich ist doch dass das
zentralorgan der medien heutzutage sehr
oft der der club der der wie nennt man
das die talkshow die politische talkshow
der wohl leute sitzen und meinungen
austauschen und da kommt eben heutzutage
glaube ich weil das spielprinzip sehr
viele redaktionen das ist dass es dann
möglich zu setzen so dass man da
möglichen kontroverse hat und da würde
ich gar nicht sein dass dann andere oder
als zu recht wahrgenommen die meinungen
nicht auftreten sondern genau weil man
diesen schritt will er nimmt man das
alles mit rein aber man lässt einen sehr
leeren streit dass man versucht mich die
verständigung sondern man doch das
spektakel auf emotionales spektakel des
großen streit aber dass und damit hat
man aber nicht wirklich zu unterschätzen
dass das ist die kraft aber sind
zugepflastert gras dass sie wenn sie so
wollen von fünf eingeladenen vier
vernünftige in anführungszeichen
einladen und einen komplett
durchgeknallten und diese kontroverse
führt dann in keinster weise dazu dass
meinungen ausgetauscht werden einst
einer der oder vielleicht auch mal zwei
die diese politisch unkorrekten
positionen vertreten die sind aber
meistens so und artikuliert und die
summe sagen so einer extremen weise auch
dass man von einer austausch von
argumenten
keine auseinandersetzung mit den
politisch unkorrekten positionen sondern
zu fahren einfach zu klauen anzunehmen
vor allen dingen gecastet wenn sie ich
kann das wirklich aus eigener erfahrung
berichten wenn sie zu einer talkshow
eingeladen werden sagen ihnen die
redakteure vorher was sie gefährlich zu
sagen haben und wenn sie diese meinung
nicht artikulieren wollen in dieser
sendung werden
aber ich würde auch hier vor zu großen
worten waren also medialer pranger ist
man zu stark dass ich tatsächlich
abspielt genauso wie punkt der mir
einfach zu stark ist und bei dem auch zu
viel bedeutung egal wie man den markt
ich sehe jetzt dass die medien betrifft
wirklich ihre analyse teilen aber
vielleicht auch nur darauf hinweisen
dass das natürlich auch im logischen
grund hat oder faktischen grund hat ein
meister darin besteht immer weniger
zeitungen immer weniger medien können
sich tatsächlich zum beispiel im netz
eigener komponenten leisten
es gibt weltweit nur noch ein paar
nachrichten agenturen die die fakten
liefern
und man weiß dass wir dann in jeder
zeitung so abgeschrieben das heißt wenn
ich in einem nachrichten-portal
sozusagen diesem bericht gewesen habe
weiß ich da wird zum überall stehen
warum soll ich da noch eine andere
zeitung erlesen
er wird dort ja mal seine meinung dazu
äußern das heißt aufgrund dieser
uniformierung tatsächlich der fakten
gezogenen nachrichten und der auswahl
auch die damit natürlich verbunden ist
jetzt immer interessanter die
interpretiert werden wird der
meinungsjournalismus natürlich auf diese
art und weise gestärkt und so spiegelt
sich auch wider
dann natürlich ein indem steigender es
daran ich muss selber zu gehen wenn ich
meinen jeden verhalten beobachte das so
in der welt da jetzt passiert ist ja das
hat man relativ schnell mitbekommen egal
über welches portal aber mich
interessiert sagen was schreibt er dazu
was er dazu
was steht dort auf der meinungsseite
wenn das auf ein getränk ist aber das
findet man doch das schon aber das
interessante ist dass da natürlich die
meinungen das übergewicht bekommen werde
faktenbasis immer vereinheitlichter um
es zu sagen immer
ich lese jetzt nicht eine andere zeitung
weil ich weiß da hat eigene
korrespondenten dort oder da und deshalb
einen eigenen blick und informationen
die die anderen nicht haben gibt die
benutzten alle die meldungen dass er
nachrichtenagentur das nicht auch zu tun
mit dem internet informationen zu suchen
daten zu suchen das ist etwas was sie
heute alles machen können aber das heißt
die gatekeeper funktion des mediums
dienst nicht mehr wichtig sondern wir
kommen
wichtig ist das einordnen und ausländer
aber so formation eine paradoxe
titelsong keeper funktion wäre wichtiger
denn je weil das was ich jetzt also die
video im internet in den diversen voran
in den blasen nachrichten finden ist so
vielfältig und oft in der tat auch so
fragwürdig dass ich etwas singulären
person mit dem was ich hört so weiß oder
mir denke er ganz ganz schwer mit magath
verändert nein es hat sich nicht
verändert
betrogen wurde schon immer gelogen wurde
auch schon immer und zwar auf allen
ebenen von allen beteiligten
es gibt eine jahrhundertelange lektüre
jahrhundertelange diskussion über das
lügen in der politik sogar die
unvermeidlichkeit des lügens in der
politik also das ist nicht mehr wählen
nach ich sehe die diskussion über feld
muss in einem etwas größeren
zusammenhang und zwar im engen
zusammenhang mit dem komplementär
probeflügen presse für meine begriffe
ist es so dass die und das kostet ja
auch bei dem thema internet und
klassische medien die klassischen medien
sind in einer ganz großen krise durch
die herausforderung der
internetbasierten sozialen medien
und so wie ich das hier hat der vorwurf
der fake news und ist das faktum der
fake news auch eine art abwehrfunktion
von seiten der klassischen massenmedien
also die klassischen massenmedien muss
kurz und einfach zu sagen würden sich
jetzt gerne in die position bringen wir
die klassischen massenmedien sind die
vertreter der informationen die ihm
letztlich die vertreter der wahrheit wir
sind noch objektiv während in den
sozialen medien es drunter und drüber
geht der jeder wahnsinn seiner website
hat und und und
sosehr natürlich die kritik an den
sozialen medien berechtigt ist würde ich
den umkehrschluss doch für wirklich naiv
halten nämlich zu glauben die
massenmedien würden tatsächlich an der
primär an der wahrheit orientiert sein
und tatsächlich objektiv bericht
erstatten
das problem bei stückes ist nämlich dass
man denkt es gäbe so etwas wie news im
sinne von rein faktische darstellung
konrad gießmann das schon darauf
hingewiesen alles was gesendet und
geschrieben wird ist hoch selektiv aus
einem unendlichen potenzial von
möglichen daten und informationen wird
punktgenau ausgesucht und zwar nicht was
wahr ist sondern was die leute
interessieren könnte was die situation
ist neu wir hatten die klassischen
massenmedien ein monopol
das heißt sie konnten sich wunderbar
etablieren und waren unangefochten das
ist jetzt mal das sieht sehr sehr viele
menschen gekürzt gerade bei meinen
studenten beispielsweise oder man
eigentlich kindern die sich gar nicht
mehr an den klassischen massenmedien
orientieren sondern sich nur noch online
über die welt im bild machen und diese
herausforderung ist es glaube ich die
zugrunde liegt dieser kontroverse lügen
presseball suspekt müssen
ich glaube nicht an der presse ist so
alt wie die presse sehr freie presse ein
liberales blatt karl marx dafür
geschrieben und der kalk aus lünen
presse mehr definitionen und er hat auch
die gegenöffentlichkeit dazu inszeniert
nämlich die fahrerin ist also karl kraus
heute wäre ein blogger wahrscheinlich
eine pleite hätte
und wer genau so eine blase produzieren
würde von vermeintlicher oder
tatsächlicher wahrheit gegenüber der
offiziellen presse unter
anführungszeichen wieder hört man
internetportale vielleicht auch tun also
das ist ein problem das mit massenmedien
sehen personen die welt gekommen ist das
natürlich nur die modernen
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten intensiviert
worden ist ausgeweitet worden ist neue
akzente bekommen hat aber als princess
problem der dringende verdacht dass
öffentliche medien zu sagen ist der
wahrheit nicht immer so genau nehmen wie
die eigene ideologie ist in den
vorstellungen von anfang an dagewesen
wird ich stimme herrn was sie sagen dass
es naiv wäre zu glauben gegenüber den
fake news gibt die objektive wahrheit
und möchte ich noch mal ganz kurz zurück
zu dem thema was wir von diskutiert und
genau darum finde ich auch diese polemik
gegen politische correctness ein problem
weil sie nämlich in ihrem kern
wissenschaft feindliches ist die
absurdität der wissenschaften dieser
geist klassenkampfes leute die sich alle
13 darüber nachzudenken dass er machte
der sprache der wissenschaft
feindlichkeit wie es genau das problem
weil mit der kommt man dann auch von
ganz naive medical von fakten und nicht
fakten also nicht nur und da könnte man
also es gibt belegte fakten die wahrheit
sind also mit diesem begriff könnt ihr
nicht operieren wir brauchen natürlich
tatsächlich an kritisch begleiten
gehören beispiel nehmen oder die die
flatter befürworter für diejenigen die
sagen die erde ist eine scheibe
das ist eine große community dass jetzt
keine fake news man kann das finden im
internet nur sagen natürlich genau dies
offenbar politisch inkorrekt zu wahren
die erde ist doch wir haben aber
elementar für uns folgendes im
kontrollieren jetzt haben dass ich
eigentlich jeden wissenschaft eigentlich
dann so zu tun als könnte man jeden mist
zu bauen und zu sagen es wird einfach
auch nicht diskreditiert aber es gibt
keine evidenzen dagegen
ich finde man muss vielleicht einfach
noch mal gibt es verschiedene stufen
also die woche kontrovers erstaunt
gesagt hat es waren ganz viele leute bei
seiner inauguration da und die
luftbilder irgendwie klage zeigt das
waren deutlich weniger als bei obama das
ist dann eine empirische evidenz
beobachtung darüber kann man diskutieren
können es war oben drauf weil es regnete
an den tag dass bei obama nicht der fall
war was die leute irgendwie immer war
seiner weniger beliebt ist was die leute
von anderen zu tun hat über das kann man
diskutieren aber über die tatsache des
bildes es gibt unterschiedliche grade
dessen worüber wir diskutieren können
also unterschiedlich basar wird man zu
sagen es gibt auch formen der
politischen korrektheit die tatsächlich
wissenschaft für endlich sehen wenn also
etwa junge studentinnen und studenten
fordern dass sie bestimmte werke der
weltliteratur nicht mehr lesen dürfen
weil es dort um die vergewaltigung raub
mord totschlag gibt also wenn ich als
kenner nicht
zu den nicht mehr den wert und den
selbstmord vorkommt dann ist das
wissenschaft feindlich par excellence
das eine in dieser art und weise zu
machen das klassische ausreißer sehen
das andere was ich dazu sagen wollte ist
diese was jetzt um zuletzt gesagt haben
doch erstens im internet wird man jeden
umsehen das funktioniert das noch noch
überhaupt nicht und und sozusagen diese
form von von trump in operation wie viel
menschen waren auf dem platz in jungen
jahren bin ich sehr oft bei
demonstrationen mitgegangen und das war
immer so dass wir in unserer eigenen
kommunikation gesagt haben es war eine
machtvolle demonstration vom präsidenten
arbeiten im polizeibericht stand 300
versprengte figuren haben sich dort
versammelt und für uns war es nicht klar
die polizei produziert verschiedensten
wusste ich es war 250 die alternativen
fakten natürlich ihre gefühlte es gibt
unterschiedliche interpretationen der
wirt mächtigkeit oder warum das so war
oder wie wirkt trotzdem war dieses
faktum selber ist nicht alternativ zum
heißt faktum ist dass gemachte
faktum ist gemacht wenn man
wissenschaftlich etwas aus diesem thema
gewinnen wollte und das wird sehr sehr
viel
dann bedeutet es darin bestehen dass der
begriff faktum selber problematisch wird
das wir uns von der naivität
verabschieden es gäbe so etwas wie die
wahre wirklichkeit die man nur abbilden
muss und sie präsentieren muss im
fernsehen oder in der zeitung alles ist
hoch selektiv alles ist konstruiert
hinter allen konstruktion steht ein
bestimmtes interesse und ich denke
die bürger sind mündig genug und klug
genug damit umzugehen und übrigens in
die meisten menschen auch mündlich und
klug genug mit solchen thesen wie die
erde ist flach cool umzugehen nimmt das
einfach zu ignorieren
also wir könnten uns auch viel
diskussionen spanien wir sagen okay die
lüge gehörte immer schon zu unserer
öffnungen zur wahrheit auch dazu und wir
verkraften dass und lass die leute reden
wir sehen die blätter welcher schluss
wir sind wie immer beim stammtisch
zunächst noch bei unserer
philosophischen deponie frau newmark was
haben die leute mitgebracht
ich wollte heute auf einen podcast
hinweisen dient der wird jetzt die
nächst zehn jahre alt viele citybikes
der das ist ein englischer podcast es
ist die großmutter aller philosophischen
port kraft von zwei englischen
philosophen john robert und david
edwards betrieben die fragen große
akademische philosophen manche bis sehr
bekannt wie nussbaum und peter singer
manche viel weniger bekannt aber
spezialisiert und sie befragen sie 15
minuten lang zu ihrem thema und sie
verpflichten akademische philosophen
daraufhin 15 minuten das verständlich zu
erklären
und ich finde es eine wunderbare art
philosophie an die öffentlichkeit zu
bringen
vielen dank sie haben ein buch
mitgebracht heraus karl heinz bohrer
jetzt ein wunderbares buch das
autobiografisch ist das aber weit
darüber hinaus uns auch ein führt in die
kultur dass deutschland nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg alle schlüsselfiguren dieser
kultur wunderbar porträtiert und zwar
aus einer ungewöhnlichen perspektive und
das hängt sehr eng mit unserem heutigen
thema zusammen eine perspektive die man
durchaus politisch unkorrekt nennen
könnte und darüber hinaus lernt man auf
diese art und weise nicht nur den
menschen karl heinz bohrer kennen
sondern auch seine theorie seine
ästhetik all das ist so klug verbogen
und vor allen dingen so brillant
geschrieben dass ich sagen kann es ist
das tollste buch eines aktuellen autos
das in den letzten jahren gelesen habe
war eine leseempfehlung und auch sie
haben einfach mitgebracht aber ein buch
mitgebracht ein bemerkenswertes buch aus
einerseits historischen gründen um das
jahr 130 versuchte sich der damals
das oft günther anders unter seinem
eigentlichen namen günter stern an der
universität frankfurt mit einer arbeit
zur musik philosophie zu habilitieren
aus politischen gründen und auch am
einspruch des damals jungen
aufstrebenden sie das offen theodor
adorno ist diese habilitation
gescheitert das buch der text diese
arbeit wurde nie veröffentlicht erst
jetzt 80 jahre nachdem entstanden ist
liegt sie endlich vor und man ist
überrascht wenn man diesen text wies
nicht nur aus historischen gründen
bemerkenswertes dokument sondern für
jeden musikliebhaber eröffnen sich ganz
neue philosophische zugänge und wählten
weil anders vor allem aus der
perspektive des höheren des musikhörens
beschreibt wie er sich im musikalischen
situationen wieder findet also auf alle
fälle ein höchst empfehlenswertes buch
damit sind ja wirklich am ende unseres
philosophischen stand ich bedanke mich
ganz herzlich
ich habe sie gut gekostet das laufen
dank dass sie hier waren mit dem
politischen maulkorb geht hier nun
gleich weiter an die sternstunde musik
nimmt sie nämlich mit auf eine reise in
den iran wo es frauen verboten ist vor
publikum solo zu singen
eine junge komponistin wagt ist dennoch
und erhebt ihre stimme
nächste woche bohren die einmal mehr
ganz tief mein kollege ist sprich mit
dem kinderarzt und entwicklungs branche
remo largo über die frage wer bin ich
und wie finde ich das leben das zu mir
passt
falls sie also noch auf der suche sind
nach der passenden existenz schauen sie
rein
und jetzt wünsche ich ihnen einen
schönen sonntag
[Musik]